how you guys been what have you been up
to
wow yeah yeah yeah what have you been a
great podcast yeah
about it I'm like that's a really
[ __ ] good question Connor what have I
done this week other than just play
Pokemon
touching grass you've been touching some
virtual I've been touching some virtual
five frames per second grass yeah
we've already established you don't see
frames you don't you can't sell this
between six times that's why that's why
you like them that's why people like
people are like oh the switch has
performance issues and this game runs
like [ __ ] I'm like what are you talking
about
exactly the same oh my God the fact that
I've seen clips and so much [ __ ] I'm
like how could you not tell the
difference this is okay so yeah I mean
there was like there was rumors going
around being like Oh if you bought the
physical copy then it runs a million
times more worse and it's a million
times more glitchy than the digital
version yeah so maybe that's why because
like mine was like I had a couple of
like because you know yeah I mean I had
a couple of like frame drops and [ __ ]
like that and a lot of parts that were
like just struggling to load
um but I weren't having like a huge
crashes like some people or something
maybe there's some truth to that matter
but um sorry I think they sold 10
million copies in the first three days
yeah are you serious yeah it's very
successful it was a very highly
anticipated series
um yeah I mean I I just finished it
yesterday actually I know nothing about
this because I don't really follow the
gaming sphere especially Pokemon yeah so
is this like a new Mainline game or is
this the ninth generation okay and is it
like 2D 3D 3D
um so so it's it's kind of like Legends
Arceus if you saw anything about that
except this time it's actually open
world unlike Arceus that was is an open
zone game and I'm like is that a Sonic
game it's like areas that are open but
then I think that's been a lot of other
games and we need a term for it we were
just like that's level yeah it's like uh
it's like Mario Odyssey right where it's
like you it's like once you open up the
world then you have free range on the
entire world and you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want in that area but in order
to open up the next Zone you have to
progress in the story right right
whereas this one is the actual first
proper Urban world where like the entire
map is actually open for you okay and
like the only like roadblocks of like
traversing through the world is like you
know you got to get your Pokemon to like
surf so you can go on the ocean or
something like that but other than that
like places you can walk it's fully open
okay okay as as somebody who's played a
[ __ ] ton of Pokemon and I don't really
feel that interested to play this new
one is there any reason I should play
the new one is there anything new
um
[Music]
not for reasons you will care about
because let me guess story yeah
story and music are probably the best in
any Pokemon game two things
let me tell you about the story and the
music it's it's incredible because the
gameplay changed at all okay so the game
okay so the gameplay Loop okay did you
play Arceus at all I did okay did you
like the gameplay Looper bosses yeah
okay then it's it's essentially the same
old Pokemon are running around all the
Pokemon are running around uh in the
open World um of course it's like I
would say was miraculously somehow less
buggy in that sense because there are
moments where like Pokemon will suddenly
appear and then you approach him and
then they just straight up disappear and
so there's like a great game I mean it's
great to stream because it's hilarious
yeah because the game is just so glitchy
and broken but like other than that like
the gameplay loop I would say is really
good and I I don't know this is like the
big argument when it comes to like every
new generation of Pokemon being like
have Pokemon designs gotten lazier or
have they gotten better it's like a
never-ending [ __ ] argument right like
you're more like you know from the brief
like pictures I saw of the new Pokemon
they look more like Digimon than Pokemon
a lot of people have said that they they
very much look like whoa okay I will say
though I think it this is probably the
one generation where I think all three
starter Pokemon are just as popular as
one another okay because like you know
how like in like gen 1 for example it's
like clearly like you know a Charmander
or Squirtle were like the top two
contenders like Bulbasaur I sleep yeah
you know and it was like there's always
one star where it's like I sleep or
there was a clear winner I feel in this
generation I've seen like almost an
equal dispersion of all three starters
because I think like all three of the
designs are really solid and like just
again like the gameplay kind of really
cult not doesn't really matter really
like what kind of study you pick at the
end of the day because it is an open
world and you can go in any direction I
want them to make starters that aren't
water fire or grass
I feel like they should do that just
like is it because of the is it because
of the the three colors that are
aesthetically pleasing is that why yeah
and why do we stick to well I guess it's
also because of the OG like triangle
right yeah like you know one is stronger
than the other you know kind of thing I
guess so but I feel like it could be
more exciting to yeah I agree with it
mix up you know just I agree because
they all get two types anyway now yeah
so it's like all right well why don't we
just do all right well it gets fire
later on or some [ __ ] yeah but I'm sure
you can like Traverse through the game
without using your starter at all yeah I
mean you normally can Pokemon's easy
enough now where you have to have one IQ
to yeah like it's it's I it's really
hard to [ __ ] up it is it is I mean is it
is it worth getting back into Pokemon
nowadays because
where did you stop I I stopped uh
Pokemon Ruby that's which yes I know I
mean you did you did it you did you did
play Peak Pokemon in my yeah yeah
because I I played red and blue I played
gold and silver then I played Ruby and I
I was like okay I think I'm done and
that's fair I think and it's been like
how many decades now yeah formula hasn't
changed and it's gotten easier yeah so I
think the reason why Pokemon has had a
lot of longevity amongst older people is
that you add the nuzlocker the
challenges yeah yeah you add a spin to
it that makes it interesting for
yourself yeah because because the way I
see the Pokemon franchise in my mind
it's it's kind of like the same way you
know isekai is for anime where it's it's
it's iterations of the same idea
well okay tell tell me wrong if you like
it I don't know I did more by that
they're both pretty I was gonna say
something like it's a lot like Game of
Thrones where it's like if you're like
if you're like six seven
no in the sense of like how the fan base
works or it's like okay if you're
already six or seven seasons in you
might as well just [ __ ] finish the
rest at that point they're all like
different games what are you talking
about
this is coming from someone who's never
seen Game of Thrones what are you
talking about Joe
um what I mean is if you're it's it's a
lot like any long-form TV series where
it's got multiple Series right or
multiple Seasons we're like okay you
enjoyed the first couple of ones okay
maybe the third or fourth one slightly
stunned to go downhill but you're
already committed at this point you
might as well I don't agree with this I
feel like I haven't enjoyed every
Pokemon game some of the Pokemon games
in in my opinion have been quite [ __ ]
like sun and moon was were pretty mid in
my opinion sword and shield was dog [ __ ]
it wasn't dog [ __ ]
um X and Y was like yeah it was okay as
well um I can't remember a single
Pokemon from sword and shield except for
like the the two characters The Sword
and the shield yeah
if you if you tell me to name any
Pokemon from that game I'm like
I'm the same though with like X and Y or
like sun and moon I'm like after that
point for me it's like after Gen 4 and
the recent one that I just played I
don't really remember it I didn't play X
and Y or son of shields that's why I
don't but I I don't I played the whole
game I don't remember any but also I I
wouldn't say it's like the Game of
Thrones analogy I'd say it's more like
well it's it's independent Series right
so there's no ongoing no okay okay is
not the same isakai Series right it's
not like we've done this is one guy in
the same world as a smartphone and
there's a different story with a
different uh the cast of characters oh
it's it's like you'll take it's like
iterations of the same kind of formula
it's it's kind of like it's like no
because that would be like
no yes
is there like an ongoing story or
something no but but like Doctor Who is
also in in the sense
but Pokemon also has callbacks as well
like there are a lot of callbacks in the
newer Generations where you wouldn't
really really understand it I think
especially in terms of like the law
which is in the same with Doctor Who
right where it's like you could just
like go straight into season 10 which is
everyone knows Doctor Who Have you I've
watched five to eleven who doesn't well
it kind of does separate but then they
do have they do have call backs and
mentions yeah I'm nervous I've never
seen the first couple of messes
haven't seen like the first four seasons
of Doctor Who no no but I still enjoyed
all the seasons I watched because they
don't heavily depend on the callbacks
like it's it's kind of like if you want
to fully hunt it's like a trash taste
episode you know you don't have to watch
the one before yeah but it's the same
thing no I mean I mean Doctor Who has
always had like one goal which is you
know for for the dogs it's you know find
Gallifrey you know find find other time
Lords and stuff like that there's always
been like one Central goal and then
you've had like story arcs that have
like come and gone with different
characters and everything but the core
idea of the show has always remained
kind of the same Pokemon's exactly the
same what's the end goal to be the very
best there are a couple of Side
characters that have their own
storylines you follow but at the end of
the day you're there to [ __ ] beat the
Elite Four and be the champion yeah
there's no need to play any Pokemon game
prior to yeah yeah I get that even I
think like black and white and black and
white too I don't even think their story
isn't necessarily like yeah
what I was trying to say is I got like
the reason I stop playing was just
because I got kind of tired of the
formula and then I was just like is
there anything what I was trying to ask
is that is there anything new to like
bring me back yes so aside from Arceus
which actually looks interesting yeah
well Arceus is not even a Mainline game
yeah like in terms of violent Scarlet
the new one yeah what what I thought was
really really cool was like the the open
world thing is of course one thing but
also now there are three branching story
lines that you can choose to do and
that's pretty cool and it's and so it's
like one of the storylines is the BTA
gyms beat the Elite Four become the
champion the standard one yeah and then
there are two other storylines that you
can do that follow two separate
characters and then well I mean at the
end of the day in order to get to like
the final end end you have to do all
three storylines anyway but you can do
this storyline in any order you want
that's cool so you can choose to be like
I'm just gonna [ __ ] Elite Four and
become the champion and then start this
next one or what I did was I did all
three simultaneously okay and so it's
like okay so I just defeated uh the
fifth gym uh you know instead of going
to the sixth gym I'm just gonna go do
this next part of this story right and
so it's kind of like a pick you're an
adventure type of style and that works
really well in like the open world
setting yeah so now it becomes like this
fresh new thing that you can do it's not
just like uh I need to make the best
team and you know become the best people
criticizing the the visuals of the game
that they don't look as good as up to
par as other Nintendo switch games okay
so one thing I I don't know if this is a
hot take but I personally don't have a
problem with like the way that the game
looks because I mean if you think about
it that just kind of how it works in the
style of Pokemon right like I can't
imagine a Pokemon game that has the
graphics of like a breath of the Wild
Well I think it's that I think they're
just saying I think a lot of criticism
was was levied at them because they're
like you know the sceneries looked
really [ __ ] boring
I've seen a lot of the screenshots of
the game like wow this this looks so
visually boring it is yeah all the
backgrounds and all the textures look
really bad but I think as well uh you
know unlike say like because you know
the one game a lot of people use to
compare his breath of the wild right
being like Oh breath of the wild had
like so much [ __ ] going on and you know
like the environment was actually like
interactive and really cool but like the
whole point of breath of the wild is to
interact with your surroundings whereas
in the Pokemon games it's not to
interact with the surroundings it's
interact with the Pokemon but I
understand that I I would be like wow
this Pokemon in this natural habitat on
this one one by one PNG texture like I'd
be like well you know yeah no could they
have done better absolutely yeah yeah so
they're getting they're going closer to
like indie horror devs really like we're
just like we're just we're just making
one big texture game Frank is doing this
really cool thing where they're bringing
back the PS2
one thing that was that has always
confused me about I guess like the
success of Pokemon like Mainline Pokemon
games right is that would you say that
there has been a Pokemon game within
like the last few years that you would
say is like an absolute must play kind
of like the kind of like killer app that
you'd see like breath of the wild or
like I like a really really highly
acclaimed game because really a lot of
people's favorite game is black and
white too A lot of people love that one
but again but the Nintendo DS era is all
I mean they're very minute changes each
one of the improvements also also I
think a lot of Pokemon fans favorite to
black and white twos because it has one
of the best stories yeah
um but if you don't give a [ __ ] about
the story of Pokemon games which a lot
of Pokemon players don't then it's like
it's there's not really there's no
gaming you have to play I think it's
Pokemon just a juggernaut of advertising
yeah oh yeah yeah and also it's easy
like you as a parent you don't have to
think about buying your kid in Pokemon
yeah as you as the parent know what
Pokemon is it's like Mario you don't
have to there isn't like a must play
Mario game there are some [ __ ]
classes
why are you saying that through
Nostalgia goggles or is that you saying
that through like Odyssey Still Remains
as like one of the best switch games
like I I think it was like my game of
the year like the year was released it
was like a [ __ ] incredible games they
looked like Zelda as well breath of the
wild completely revolutionized the
gaming uh the open world the open world
genre after it got released so there
have been like there have been like big
IPS that have that have had killer apps
but for me it always confuse me about
Pokemon is that it sells like [ __ ]
hotcakes it's it it breaks every kind of
record imaginable and then I look at the
game reviews and then every every time a
new game comes out it's like yes it's
all right it's good it's because it's
because I feel Pokemon generally are
appealing to two types of player bases
the children and the old school Pokemon
fans right right they're not trying to
get like this new adult fan base the who
has never played Pokemon before because
they know there's no Pokemon game that
they can make that will be like like a
20 year old you know kid yeah who's
never played a Pokemon game will be like
yeah you know what I should give that
game a go you know they're not gonna do
that it's like water everyone drinks
water whereas breath of the wild is like
the most Exquisite wine oh [ __ ] I gotta
be 21. I gotta have some money oh man
they're gonna be in wine like if you
like this it's on carry on again it's
the best thing ever if you if you have
that that you know you want to get into
it but Pokemon is so so basic Fiji Water
again
anyone can drink it
I don't know if that anyone likes it
yeah everyone's good everyone's gonna
drink it but no one's gonna be you know
ejaculating over a bottle of Fiji Water
you know they're just gonna be like yeah
it quenched my thirst yeah I'm satisfied
I I yeah I don't know personally I'm
just like kind of over Pokemon I'm like
I kind of enjoy it when there's a nozzle
or something fun to do no and I and
that's the thing I totally get that
which is why I always find it
frustrating when these [ __ ] Pokemon
fans are like no no I swear this is the
new this is the generation that everyone
has to play I'm like no they don't
because at the end of the day it's a
[ __ ] children's game they want to say
that I thought Pokemon fans hate
everything they do oh okay but Pokemon
fans are the type of [ __ ] who
would be like you know first week of
violent scholar coming up being late
this game looks like [ __ ] and then a
week later they'll be like all right
I'll give it